- Yeah, it is a great
sweatshirt, thank you.
(whoosh)
(thud)
Hey guys! Bonus video this week!
Hooray!
Hopefully most of you are saying.
Hair and makeup done
while wearing sweatshirt
with my dog's face on it,
leggings, bourgeois socks
and some Uggs.
Yeah, that's the formula for a style icon.
Me!
I even wrote a whole book on style,
called "Grace and Style: The
Art of Pretending You Have It".
And it's available for presale right now
because it comes out February 2nd.
(whispers) February 2nd.
This shot is mostly because
I got a new camera that
autofocuses and I'm testing it.
My eye shadow's been on my
eyes for almost 12 hours.
Say it with me.
Style icon!
Or it means that I just
finished a 12-hour day on set
for Dirty Thirty, the new
movie that we're shooting.
No one knows which one it is.
Look at this eye shadow.
Does this increase your
want to own my style book?
No.
Look, I own makeup!
But...
Butts, always in style.
More great style tips like that in
"Grace and Style: The Art
of Pretending You Have It"
available February 2nd, but currently
available for presale.
And this whole video
is to let you know that
there has been a sweepstakes
that has launched
around the launch of the book.
(Shaggy's "It Wasn't Me")
What does--
What does a--
What's-- what's a dom--
What's a domestic goddess'
favorite kind of contest?
A sweep steak.
She loves barbecue and cleaning.
More hilarious comedy like that in
"Grace and Style: The Art
of Pretending You Have It".
But let's get into more
about these sweepstakes.
That's maybe what you're here for.
Maybe you clicked on this video and then
your mouse battery died and you're just
shit out of luck.
Feel shit out of luck?
Why not preorder "Grace
and Style: The Art of
Pretending You Have It"?
All you have to do to win a
prize in the Grace and Style
sweepstakes is preorder
"Grace and Style: The Art of
Pretending You Have It" right now.
That is very easy to do.
And here are the prizes.
30 first prize winners
will receive a tote bag
designed by me.
Can you believe that they let
a person that looks like this
design a tote bag?
Life is strange.
Five runners up will receive
a Grace and Style necklace.
There is one!
There will be.
Hopefully you have a neck.
A signed book and a
personalized style chat with me,
fashion's best kept secret.
And finally, there will
be one grand prize winner
that will receive a
personalized style chat with me,
fashion's best kept
secret/unfortunate, can't-get-rid-of
sibling, me, Grace Helbig.
A signed copy of the book,
a tote bag designed by me
and all of some of my
favorite beauty items.
So, if you want a chance to win any
of those super, wonderfully fun, more
adjective-worthy prizes,
then pre order your copy of
"Grace and Style: The Art
of Pretending You Have It"
right now, please.
I really like this book a lot
and I think you'll like it.
And that's all I wanted to tell you today.
I need to save my voice.
Who am I kidding?
Style icon.
I don't know.
And I'm sorry, most of the world,
but the sweepstakes,
unfortunately because of
weird legal reasons that
I don't even understand,
is only open to the US and Canada.
(whispers) I'm so sorry.
I don't--
I didn't go to law school,
so I don't know why.
I just know if we let everyone participate
we will get in trouble.
And the only police that I
really would be okay with
getting arrested by in my
life are the fashion police.
But that would never happen.